[Música]
Hola soy Natalia Cabrera parada y esto
es aquí América el programa de France 24
para revisar en profundidad todas las
noticias y las historias de nuestro
continente y Estos son nuestros
titulares el régimen autocrático de
Daniel Ortega se consolida y le quita la
nacionalidad a otras 94 personas son 317
personas despojadas de su derecho humano
por alzar su voz en contra de su
acumulación del Poder y sus movimientos
ilegales para mantenerse además al mando
del país centroamericano y con un sesgo
racista han actuado las fuerzas de
seguridad en Perú para reprimir las
protestas en contra de Dina boluarte que
dejan más de 60 muertos según reveló un
informe de la organización amnistía
internacional tras dos meses de
investigaciones
y vamos a ir a Brasil que esta de
carnaval una fiesta para la que las
escuelas de Río de Janeiro se preparan
durante todo el año los corresponsales
de France 24 estuvieron en uno de los
ensayos
y vamos de inmediato con nuestra
historia principal Daniel Ortega le
quitó la nacionalidad a 94 personas por
lo que considera es traición a la patria
un paso más en la consolidación de su
régimen antidemocrático y de persecución
a la oposición y que se da tras el
destierro de 222 personas la semana
pasada recordemos que se trata de
personas que aspiraron a hacerle
competencia en las elecciones
presidenciales en las que se reeligió en
2021 o estudiantes que se levantaron en
su contra en 2019 entre ellos también
hay incluso 22 periodistas cuya labor Es
simplemente informar y mientras
organizaciones advierten de que la
medida de quitar la nacionalidad a los
ciudadanos viola el artículo 15 de la
declaración universal de Derechos
Humanos algunos países de la región
mantienen su silencio o no han sido
vehementes en su condena por una
decisión que es completamente ilegal
Solo hasta esta semana Estados Unidos
condenó la medida pues la anterior Joe
biden se enfocaba en la liberación que
si bien es positiva no deja de ser un
atentado a las libertades
Estados Unidos condena la decisión del
gobierno de Nicaragua de quitarle la
nacionalidad a 94 de sus ciudadanos y la
revocatoria de la ciudadanía de los 222
presos políticos liberados la semana
pasada estos actos son inconsistentes
con la declaración universal de los
Derechos Humanos que establece que todas
las personas tienen derecho a una
nacionalidad marca otros retroceso para
el pueblo nicaragüense y un paso
adelante hacia la consolidación de un
régimen autocrático y en cuanto a las
mayores potencias de América Latina por
México Andrés Manuel López Obrador no se
ha manifestado argumentando su política
de no intervención tampoco el brasileño
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva ni el
argentino Alberto Fernández El
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro sí
manifestó su preocupación por la
situación pero no la condenó la única
condena vehemente ha sido la de la
administración de Gabriel borich a
través de su cancillería sobre esto
vamos a hablar con Patricia Luna
corresponsal de France 24 en Santiago
Patricia qué fue lo que dijo la
canciller
los hechos de las últimas semanas
demuestran que se trata cada día más de
una dictadura totalitaria que persigue
cualquier tipo de incidencia con estas
palabras categóricas se manifestaba la
canciller chilena Antonia urejola sobre
la anulación de la nacionalidad a 94
personas nicaragüenses entre las que se
encuentran destacados escritores como
Sergio Ramírez o yoconda belli mujeres
defensoras de los Derechos Humanos
feministas periodistas y otros destacó
la canciller que también hizo un balance
de la situación alarmante que se vive en
el país al respecto donde existen más de
230 presos políticos a los que se les ha
confiscado los bienes anulado la
nacionalidad en el caso de estos 94
además de anularles la nacionalidad y
confiscarle los bienes también se les ha
declarado prófugos de la justicia algo
que estableció es de suma gravedad la
canciller afirmó que el gobierno de
chile Va a continuar trabajando para
denunciar estos hechos y situarse del
lado de los perseguidos hizo también un
llamado a la comunidad internacional a
que se sitúe a la altura recordemos que
rej fue parte de la Comisión
Interamericana para los derechos humanos
y que presidió este organismo en 2021 es
lo dicho por la canciller se suma a las
declaraciones realizadas por el
presidente Gabriel boric desde que
asumió incluso antes Incluso en las
últimas semanas en la Cumbre de las
comunidades de Estados latinoamericanos
y caribeños la cela que tuvo lugar en
Buenos Aires solicitaba al gobierno de
Daniel Ortega la liberación de los
detenidos opositores que se encontraban
en situación indigna la posición del
gobierno de Gabriel borich ha sido
siempre inequívocamente Y de forma
coherente contraria a la situación
política que se vive en el país
centroamericano nos vamos a Perú para
revisar la cifra de la semana 16 por
ciento Esa es la cifra de aprobación de
la presidenta Dina boluarte más baja que
la de su antecesor Pedro Castillo quien
lograba el
24%. entre tanto la organización
amnistía internacional denunció que
Durante los dos meses del mandato de
boluarte
las fuerzas de seguridad han respondido
con el uso excesivo de la fuerza a las
protestas en su contra y con un sesgo
racista veamos el informe de amal
benotman
en Perú desde el inicio de las
manifestaciones contra la destitución y
la detención del expresidente Pedro
Castillo cerca de 60 personas han
perdido la vida según la organización de
Derechos Humanos amnistía internacional
hay pruebas de la implicación del
ejército y la policía en estas muertes
nos encontramos frente no solo graves
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos sino
crímenes bajo el derecho internacional
podemos
evidenciar que han habido ataques
generalizados en contra de la población
civil Para apoyar estas acusaciones la
ong recogió testimonios de víctimas y de
sus familiares en Lima ayacucho
andahuaylas y puno también se basó en
informes de las autoridades peruanas las
protestas en Perú comenzaron El Siete de
diciembre desde entonces manifestantes a
menudo de origen pobre y campesino se
enfrentan con la policía amnistía
internacional reportó que además los
ataques contra la población han tenido
un discriminatorio como lo ha explicado
a France 24 Pilar San Martín
investigadora para América de amnistía
internacional hay un marcado sesgo
racista porque no se actúa y la policía
no actúa de la misma manera cuando la
población no está racionalizada que
cuando la población lo está aparte de
esto hemos visto discursos sumamente
racistas por parte de las autoridades
Vimos a la presidenta Dina boluarte
incluso afirmar que la región de puno no
es Perú hemos visto como se estigmatiza
cómo se criminaliza diciendo que los
manifestantes son terroristas son
criminales sin que el estado haya
aportado ninguna prueba los
manifestantes peruanos exigen nuevas
elecciones la destitución de la actual
presidenta la renovación del Congreso y
un nuevo proceso constitucional a pesar
de la amplitud del movimiento Dina
boluarte sucesora de Pedro Castillo no
parece estar dispuesta a exceder asegura
que nunca ha dado órdenes de utilizar
armas letales para controlar a los
manifestantes
desarrollándose y después de Perú
Bolivia y Guatemala Panamá es el país de
la región que tiene el mayor porcentaje
de población indígena más del
14%, según la organización Internacional
del trabajo solo 37% de ellos tiene un
empleo el resto se ve obligado a la
informalidad e incluso al trabajo no
remunerado el corresponsal de France 24
en el país centroamericano Oscar
sulbarán nos cuenta más
la falta de oportunidades laborales en
tierras indígenas trajo a eustasio hasta
la capital panameña Hace seis años el
panorama no ha cambiado para él y su
familia trata de mantener esta
improvisado hogar con menos de 5 dólares
al día trabajando como vigilante de la
raza nosotros son criticado porque ahí
hay al interior son casi de trabajo
Plaza de trabajo no hay y allá se gana
un poquito menos la de acá menos Porque
allá se gana se gana cuatro dólares
por día allá no se gana por hora se gana
por día una ocupación muy común dentro
de las mujeres indígenas que viven en
esta zona rural de Ciudad de Panamá es
la costura se convierte en una forma
para conseguir ingresos en un ambiente
con pocas opciones laborales y donde
además tienen que mantenerse a cargo del
cuidado de sus hijos como lo hace
Elizabeth siempre he tenido a punto de
coser la ropa
mantenido a punto de coser la ropa Vendo
ropa y coso y no me manda a coser y así
lo compro y así lo mantengo los niños en
esta fábrica de ladrillos al menos a la
mitad de sus trabajadores eran indígenas
lo que era una opción estable para
algunos de ellos ha desaparecido aquí
siempre hemos tenido aproximadamente de
78 empleados todos de la comunidad entre
campesinos indígenas que somos los que
vivimos en esta área
pero
ahí ya definitivo aproximadamente seis
meses que aquí tuvimos que liquidar a
todo el mundo
ya para nosotros seguir subsistiendo yo
mismo he tenido que empezar a trabajar
solo aquí de nuevo mientras eustasio y
Elizabeth te esperan por mejores
oportunidades lejos de su territorio
ancestral gobierno panameño realiza un
censo de población que le permitirá
tener mayor información de la realidad
socioeconómica de los pueblos indígenas
del país
empezó el carnaval de Río de Janeiro un
espectáculo para el que todo el año las
escuelas de samba ensayan para que todo
salga perfecto Durante los 75 minutos
que dura el desfile en el sambódromo
cientos de personas doran su tiempo a
cambio de un disfraz que les brindará
poco más de una hora de emociones
inolvidables los corresponsales de
France 24 estuvieron con una escuela de
samba
[Música]
para ser reina de una escuela de samba
hace falta un torrente de energía y una
gran coordinación con los percusionistas
mayara nació en Ciudad de Dios la Favela
conocida en todo el mundo por la
película homónima es considerada una de
las mejores bailarinas de la nueva
generación de sambistas Hasta el punto
que el año pasado hubo un clamor popular
para que fuese declarada reina de la
escuela paraíso de tuyuchi
Yo casi siempre estoy escuchando a
nuestros percusionistas le pido siempre
al director de la batería que me mande
los últimos arreglos para poderlos
aprender porque mi cuerpo es eso mi
cuerpo es música y danza yo coloco todos
los instrumentos de la batería en mi
cuerpo
cada escuela de samba está dividida en
alas no pueden faltar los fascistas que
bailan la Samba la comisión de
vanguardia que ejecuta una coreografía
para insignificar el tema de la canción
un ala de bayanas las mujeres mayores
que representan la tradición de la Samba
Y por supuesto el abanderado y su
doncella que levantan el estandarte de
la escuela
delante de los jurados la bandera no
puede quedar enrollada ni caer ni
golpearse contra el suelo Tampoco puede
caer ningún elemento de nuestra ropa
mientras estamos bailando
el desfile en el sambodromo es una ópera
itinerante donde cada detalle importa
todos los años cada escuela tiene que
producir un espectáculo diferente y
presentar una trama original
desarrollada a través de la canción de
los disfraces y de la danza
el entusiasmo es un requisito
indispensable
la mejor parte ocurre antes aquí antes
del carnaval el espectáculo en el
sambodromo es para que el mundo lo vea
el espectáculo del pueblo El que
emociona De verdad está aquí el alma de
la escuela el alma del sambista están
aquí en el ensayo
y el público participa vibrando a cada
nota la Samba consigue reunir a
generaciones y personas desconocidas a
través de un sentimiento inexplicable
una pasión tan Arrolladora que permite
vencer Incluso el calor tórrido del
verano carioca
[Música]
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí América por favor envíenme sus
comentarios en redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla en la
producción estuvo Jennifer Guevara
pueden ver esta emisión y las anteriores
en nuestra página web y Para más
información de nuestro continente Sigan
viendo franz24 y France 24.com
[Música]